the following contains spoilers for the
upcoming season of Game of Thrones hey
guys 2 down bring your fate of Jamie
Lannister a video that was highly
requested in comment section this video
contains a lot of leaked photos which
are supporting all the theories that you
are going to hear in this video there
are a lot of information so let's just
jump into it if you thought that Jamie
is going to turn his back on Cersei
after we've seen his final scene in
season 6 any Jaime entered the iron
throne room in which her she was
proclaimed as a new queen Iran but not
completely the final scene of Jaime in
season 6 almost convinced us the Jaime
won't be by his side any more his face
expression while he was looking sir see
sitting on the Iron Throne was full of
an anger full of disdain however from
leaked photos we can clearly see him
fighting to improve Lannisters position
but that doesn't has to mean that he
will support Cersei
I mean Jaime Lannister and he's going to
do everything to defend his house from
its extinction let's start with leaked
photos from Croatia we're feeling lasted
only for a few days if you didn't watch
my previous videos Croatian City
Dubrovnik hosted Game of Thrones crew
along with few main actors such as Jaime
Cersei and the mountain along with
extras with the petty gold cloaks aka
the city watch and youngsters
queensguard with stunning new armors by
the way do burnick will represent parts
of King's Landing just like in previous
seasons Game of Thrones mostly came back
to filming - burning because of Fort
Booker which was in previous season film
conversation between Tyrion and Varys
first day of filming do Bernick was at
Fort Booker on which we've seen Jaime
and Cersei along with director Jeremy
Podesta Lena Headey known as Cersei and
Nikolaj coster-waldau known as Jaime
were only attended on the first day of
filming in Dubrovnik while on few other
days of filming only director Jeremy
Podesta along with filming crew
continued filming now those scenes won't
be very important in the upcoming season
those scenes of Jaime and Cersei will
only contain a few minute conversation
between these two which will considering
that Jeremy Podesta is directing season
7 premiere and finale those things will
be in the first episode of the upcoming
season it's most likely the Daryl
relationship
be the same as it has been back in
previous seasons mostly because of Jamie
Jamie won't look at Cersei as he once
has he won't feel any love towards
Cersei anymore their relationship will
be based only on formality which is a
result of Cersei using wild fire to kill
her enemies sir tickling her enemies
wouldn't concern Jamie if Cersei didn't
also kill a lot of innocent people
same people Jaime once protected from
the maderas by killing this same King
the king whom he was supposed to protect
with his own life in league but there
stated the Lannisters will sack
Highgarden in with Jaime will also
confront Olenna Tyrell this we can call
it theory has already came true with a
bunch of leaked photos as a proof before
we focus on those leaked photos let's
just say the Cersei will in the upcoming
season need to make a new alliance since
she killed the only Lancer strong ally
with wildfire well we don't have to
wonder anymore who Cersei Ally is going
to be since we can see from leaked
photos that randyll Tarly is going to be
a new Lannisters Ally as we have already
seen from linked photos the result of
that alliance is going to be Jaime
Lannister leading Lannister army along
with Randall and Deacon Tarly leading
their table are me they're going to
march in Highgarden and also from link
photos we've seen the outcome of that
battle which will result with Jaime's
and Randall's victory that is not
surprising at all
Jamie Randall will have numbers there
what number Tyrell soldiers and both of
them have a lot of military experience
particularly randyll Tarly who is known
as one of the best commanders in the
Seven Kingdoms
well this March and the assault of
Highgarden are confirmed by leaked
photos aliquot Jaime also confront
Olenna Tyrell while is that high guard
according to leaked plot lady Elena will
admit to Jaime everything about how she
and Littlefinger poison Joffrey which
will end the Jaime long and Elena to
drink poison and kill herself before
getting captured after they are going to
conquer Highgarden Jamie Randall with
their armies will march back home with
carriages full of goods slowly from
Highgarden as we can see from link
photos well Derek any home the nurses
army will attack genius and Reynolds
army and take an opportunity to fight
them
on the open field this huge battle will
start with the Trekkie
ambush between the battle the nurse will
also be riding dragon how can we know
for sure well I didn't see dragon leg
photos but from leaked photos we can see
a lot of smoke and burned carriages
which I believe is the result of drones
fire breeding this battle will end with
a lot of casualties for both sides as
you can see a lot of that man on the
ground but it's going to be Daenerys
victory however during this battle
Randall and Deacon Tarly are going to
get captured while bran will save Jamie
from almost getting killed whereupon
they are going to escape and most likely
go to Casterly Rock Casterly Rock will
be represented by Trujillo castle in the
upcoming season as we can see a lot like
photos from set at Trujillo castle along
with Jaime and Bronn on its walls
Casterly Rock is crawled out of great
stone hill colossal rock beside the
sunset sea the base of the rock contains
large sea card Cameron's there are
hundreds of mine shafts in the deaths of
the rock as well as yet untouched gold
veins drug has been measured to three
times the height of the wall or the high
tower of Old Town its board has docks
wharves and shipyards and is accessible
by long ships and cogs because of all
these specifications the Casterly Rock
is an ideal shelter for Jamie but he
won't stay long in the Casterly Rock
Jamie will go back to King's Landing so
yeah
finally in season 7 we're going to see
Casterly Rock for the first time
meanwhile according to leaked plot Jaime
and Bronn will secretly meet with Tyrion
in Dallas meeting in which Tyrion is
going to try to convince his brother
Jaime to join him to join the we can
call it good side but Jamie's going to
refuse with Damian at his Lannister and
that he would never betray his house
well that shame his opinion before
knowing search his opinion about the
undead army before search this
announcement about marrying urine as a
result of all that Jaime will decide to
we can call it how to save the world
Jaime will kill once again the one who
he was supposed to protect his own life
but also Jaime will once again save a
lot of innocent lives Jamie's going to
kill Cersei but let's get a little bit
back let's get back on the events that
are going to lead Jay
me to kill his ones beloved sister and
lover sir see it's important for you at
this point now that after the nurses
ambush and Jameson Randall's defeat
totally army will be weak a Lannister
army we can say is going to be weak but
won't be powerful as it once had been at
the sponsors will be desperate their
enemies all around her she doesn't have
any remaining ally to protect her while
her army won't be powerful enough to
destroy all over enemies that's the
moment in which urine is coming to
King's Landing after he successfully
defeated Yara along with sand snakes
that's the moment in which turn will
come to King's Landing parading with his
prisoners and he's going to pledge his
army and iron fleet to Cersei but in
return
Cersei will head to marry him similar
deal as he had for Daenerys let's deal
with her she will accept
that's the deal which will bring her
hopes hopes that her reign is going to
last a little bit longer that's a little
bit Cersei knows she has to accept
otherwise her reign is over next what is
going to happen is the scene from dragon
pit in which all main characters will
attend and by the way it's also
confirmed on that we can call a meeting
17 major characters are going to attend
which makes this scenes having a big
role in season 7 and the outcome of that
meeting which is going to be organized
by Daenerys and John in favor to show
all the Lords the real threat that all
of them are facing in favour to unite
their armies to have a chance against
the undead army is going to have a great
importance for the events to come in
season 8 considering that most probably
this scene is going to be released in
season 7 finale while old Lords and
powerful people are going to groovy
Daenerys and will agree to reunite all
of their armies on but Cersei Cersei
won't consider the situation as everyone
else does Cersei will welcome the undead
army in her opinion the White Walkers
along with their white horde are going
to defeat all of our enemies which would
only benefit her according to leaked pot
gemilut can't assert CNS or permission
to lead Lannister army to the north to
join the great battle to join all other
armies but Sir she refused his request
along with telling him her opinion about
the undead army which I have told you a
few moments ago
Jaime is going to be speechless Jaime
won't believe what Cersei just said
furthermore by teary mine that moment
sir sir will also announce the Jamie
that she's going to marry urine in a few
days
Jamie disappointing by Circe's opinion
we'll think about leaving King's Landing
and support the living side with his
experience in leading an army that same
day sir sir we'll get married to your
own Greyjoy
while Jamie will finish his preparations
to leave King's Landing just before
Jamie leaves he's going to feel the need
to see Cersei once again and to tell her
that he is leaving and is going to
support the leaning side it's going to
be meeting in which sir she won't show
her feelings furthermore by my theory
sir she will mock him
sir she will tell him that she doesn't
need him anymore that she now has her
husband husband who has the biggest
fleet and army to support her Jaime
frustrated by those Circe statements
encouraged by the fact that she and
urine once in her arm snort Army's dead
links I desperately needs Jaime will
decide to kill her he details to
strangle Cersei to that along with
killing urine most likely with someone
else's help
after that Jaime will join the we can
call it the war between life and death
along with Lannister army I'm rooting
for this theory of mine to come true I'm
ruining for Jamie to finally find out
who his sister and lover truly is I'm
rooting for Jamie to kill Cersei mostly
because it would kind of make sense I
mean it really seems that Game of
Thrones co-creators David Benioff and
Dan Weiss are trying ever since the
third season to rise Jamin arise I don't
think that David and Dan gave us all
scenes including the one in regime is
set to Brienne that he killed his King
Aerys Targaryen because the King wanted
to burn the whole King's Landing by
using wildfire I don't think that they
gave us these scenes for no particular
reason just be aware that this is Game
of Thrones everything happens for a
reason in my opinion the scene between
Jaime and Brienne in which Jaime said to
bring the truth the real reason of his
let's call it betrayal or the Mad King
it could represent foreshadow of a Jaime
killing Cersei I don't know if it's only
my thought I don't know it's theory of
mine is the only product of my
overthinking but history makes sense to
me if you would like to hear this theory
of mine about the new red wedding
between your answers in details
the gold wedding feel free to check that
video as well after all of these
confirmed theories sent errors that
might come true let's now focus on a
fact which we can see link photos of
Jamie from the shooting set at Trujillo
castle let's focus on one leaked photo
from filming set a Trujillo castle which
shoves us a new sword the Jaime is going
to build in season 7 it's new old sword
King Joffrey's Valyrian steel sword
videos Vale videos Vale is the second
Valyrian steel blade made from the ice
the blade of House Stark the blade that
Ned Stark wilted until he was beheaded
with this same sword the widow's wail
and Oathkeeper are two swords made from
sword ice steel under orders of Tywin
Lannister firstly Jamie had sword
Oathkeeper which was a gift from his
father timing as intention of making him
to be released from his vows as Lord
Commander of the Kingsguard and rule
over Casterly Rock in his stead Jaime
refused his father's offer to roll over
Casterly Rock but I'm still let him keep
sword anyway other Kings Joffrey's death
Jaime or de Brienne to find Sansa Stark
and get her somewhere safe before Cersei
manages to find her as a parting gift he
gave Brienne his sword old keeper as he
knows it was forged from ice so she can
protect Ned Stark's daughter with Ned
Stark's own steel Jaime also gave
Brienne that sword to fulfill the vow
him a to Catelyn which was to get her
daughters to safety sword widows Vale
was gifted by time and Lannister as a
wedding gift to his grandson King
Joffrey Baratheon last time I've seen
widows wail was during the funeral
service in the great Sept of Baelor the
sword was placed on long Joffrey's
corpse
apparently upon Joffrey's death this war
was given to his younger brother and
heir King Tommen Baratheon
it was not clear what happened or what
will happen with the widow's wail
after King Tommen committed suicide at
least until now in conclusion I'm just
going to say that I'm surely rooting for
Jaime to finally turn his back to Cersei
I'm rooting for him to lead a Lannister
army to the north to support the living
side I'm ruining for Jaime to prove that
he still has an honor the honour which
he sacrifice
on the day he killed the Mad King the
honor which he sacrificed in favor to
save hundreds of thousands innocent
lives hope you guys enjoyed this video
if you did please make sure to subscribe
to our Channel and hope to see in the
next one peace
[Music]
you